we keep trying to measure it all in
external are we doing important work
doing important work with your life
doing something really meaningful
whatever you do you do it consciously
and you are doing the optimum thing at
that moment
if you walk into a grocery store and
you're in such a rush to get home to
meditate
that when you get to the cashier's desk
you get frustrated with her because
she's holding you up and therefore you
send forth a vibration of anger which
makes her tighter you've just created
new karma that
boy
the game is to not create new karma and
then just finish off the old tongue
and you don't create new karma when you
perform every act without attachment
do what you do but do it without
attachment and then there's no new karma
crew
all i am is where i am at i
am where i am and i am what i am
and if what i am is wise to you groovy
i am what i am i don't know where i am
and i don't even really care where i am
that's the thing
i don't i don't think about the question
of the answer
i could say if i wanted to answer yes
and then again no
because obviously i'm a beginner on the
path and i don't understand a great deal
of stuff
and at the same time i know much more
than i ever knew before
i feel more about how it is the less i
think the wiser
i get i knows which blows my mind having
been a scientist
that's